existe um poder mágico em contar
histórias
especialmente quando a gente está
falando da nossa própria história mas
nem sempre é fácil e eu vou começar
minha
antes mesmo do meu nascimento quando os
meus avós vieram no interior do ceará
com nove filhos 16 uma viagem de três
dias de ônibus para formar uma família e
se mudar para um barraco de madeira no
alto da favela da rocinha
eu só vai fazer um bico para sustentar a
família
não vou por exemplo fazia bicos de
marceneiro pedreiro carpinteiro meu avô
ou entre um trabalho aqui e outro ali
fazia estantes para livros que ele não
podia ler mas também não puderam
concluir o ensino fundamental mas sempre
valorizaram muito educação e dava pra
perceber isso por exemplo quando meu pai
me levava para a escola e dormia cansado
depois de uma noite no restaurante ou
quando minha mãe e me buscar na escola
no intervalo que ela tinha como
empregada doméstica desvalorizavam tanto
educação vocês podem ver com o
aniversário de cinco anos do tema escola
se eles acreditavam tanto assim na
educação
quem seria eu para duvidar
eu dei uma escola municipal do rio de
janeiro embora ela estivesse num bairro
nobre ela sofria de penúria de uma
escola pública
falta de professor greve falta de
estrutura
uma escola tinha determinado momento
chegou a ter o pior ideb do estado
eu aprendi muita coisa valiosa nessa
escola muitas coisas que eu carrego
comigo até hoje
mas também eu aprendi nessa escola
algumas coisas sobre educação e de como
ela não deveria ser eu tinha alguns
professores que é o primeiro sinal de
bagunça diziam pra gente olha vocês vão
fazendo bagunça é por isso que você não
chegar a lugar nenhum
ou então quando a gente não conseguia
entender um determinado conceito da
matéria eles diziam meus alunos da
escola particular está muito na frente
vocês estão ficando para trás
de fato a gente estava para trás
eu tinha alguns colegas que tinham
problemas com violência doméstica o
político da família e desemprego que
falta gente estava para trás a gente
demorava mais para chegar à escola
porque o ônibus demorava isso quando
faltava luiz quando faltava água
saneamento básico e às vezes a gente
tinha que ir à escola e fugindo de
tiroteios que atinge a gente mesmo uma
eo preconceito
segundo uma pesquisa do data popular e
da cufa 49 por cento quase metade dos
jovens entre 15 e 25 anos que mora em
favelas cariocas têm vergonha de dizer
de onde vem
jovens como eu que aos 16 anos de idade
quando estava no curso de inglês
bolsista
o tema da aula era onde você mora
naquele momento eu fui para o banheiro e
comecei a chorar
disposto a sair de lá só quando passar
se eu tivesse certeza que tivesse
passado momento respondi a essa pergunta
onde você mora mas assim como tem
professores que acabam causando na gente
às vezes um certo puxar para trás tem
outros que empurram para frente tem
outros que acreditam muito no potencial
transformador da educação
duas dessas professoras eu trago para
representar vários outros que perderam
horas de seus dias fora de sala de aula
na hora do recreio dentro da própria
casa ajudando a passar por de um
concurso para uma escola melhor e foi
assim depois de três tentativas e não
passei na primeira não passei na segunda
e só na terceira tentativa eu passei eu
fui aprovado pro colégio pedro 2º
colégio de muitas histórias mais uma
ilha uma ilha de excelência em três
escolas públicas
bom eu achava que entrar pedro 2º seria
mais difícil mas na verdade é mais
difícil mesmo era permanecer lá por que
logo no primeiro trimestre estava em
operação em cinco matérias
bom eu precisava me recuperar lá na
rocinha tinha um projeto social que
ajudava crianças com dificuldades de
aprendizagem
não há dificuldade de aprendizagem foi
exatamente a minha dificuldade eu tinha
grupos culturais comparados a outros
jovens de classe média de fato e deixava
para um pouco para trás a falta de
acesso a livros a cinema teatro etc
mas eu precisava me recuperar nesse
projeto social embora a gente tivesse
ótimos vontade por lá eles não estavam
muito preparados para o tipo de
dificuldade que eu estava levando como
por exemplo a forma de baixo
a propósito todo dia eu vou dormir tanto
futebol foi hoje que o dia forma de
básica
mas apesar disso é eu percebia entre os
meus colegas que eu consegui ajudar eles
por exemplo calculando a área de um
triângulo e se eu sabia fazer o que eu
percebi poder transformador da educação
quando você compartilha aquilo que você
sabe porque às vezes o que parece pouco
pra você é muito pra outra pessoa
foi aí que percebi que tem muito a
aprender
no ato de ensinar bom é eu tive que
deixar o projeto social eu dei aula por
lá mas tive que deixar o projeto social
em 2004 porque em 2004 eu fui aprovado
no curso de direito da universidade do
estado do rio de janeiro
na época um dos cursos mais concorridos
eu acreditava como um jovem idealista
que eu ia conseguir mudar o mundo pelo
direito que eu ia conseguir fazer a
transformação por justiça e igualdade é
para acesso à moradia acesso à saúde
acesso à educação mas pra mim não seria
pelo direito que eu ia conseguir fazer a
transformação que eu queria ver no mundo
foi aí que no final da faculdade eu
comecei a estagiar numa empresa aqui no
rio de janeiro encontrei um cara também
idealista
encontrei um cara também idealista e ele
falou o seguinte é bom olha todo direito
também não não acho que eu vou conseguir
fazer a mudança que eu quero ver no
mundo que tal a gente então empreender
em educação
aí eu pensei advogados recém formados
têm pouco de educação tendo um pouco de
empresa não tem um centavo no bolso e
quer empreender
e foi aí que eu enfim entrar nessa
jornada com pedro e durante essa jornada
a gente fez muito muito teste ea gente
também ouviu muito os professores é
essencial pra gente ouvir os professores
enfim a gente começou a fazer teste a
gente queria fazer mudança pela educação
queria que fosse pela leitura e pela
escrita que são elementos são basilares
para a educação
a gente tentou de tudo a gente fez feira
literária gente roda de leitura a gente
tentou vender livros criativos até
fantasiar de mago pra fazer festa de
aniversário a gente fez esse é o maior
legado button sabe do nosso mascote bom
é e quando eu falei de ouvir professores
a gente faz isso até hoje a gente ouvir
os professores traz os professores para
conversar com a gente porque quem
entende de sala de aula é quem está na
sala de aula
é por isso que a gente ouviu tanto os
professores eles diziam olha aqui a
gente tem um projeto onde os nossos
alunos escreve um livro ou seja tão
legal que o meu aluno pudesse escrever o
próprio livro
a gente pensava caramba a gente vai
fazer isso não é um livro por criança
como é que a gente torna isso
economicamente viável de uma forma
democrática com acesso e aí foram mais
noites de estudos até a gente
desenvolver um modelo que a gente
aplicou na primeira escola em 2012
o modelo funciona da seguinte maneira a
escola tem acesso à nossa plataforma e
na plataforma é o acesso dos nossos
projetos pedagógicos ou se ela já tiver
o seu próprio projeto pedagógico ela
pode dentro de seu planejamento scola
aplicar a enfim a elaboração de um livro
onde as crianças elas ilustram e escreve
a própria história pode ser tema livre
pode ser um tema orientado mas sempre
acompanhado de supervisionado pelos
professores
depois que eles terminam e ele ficou
muito ansiosos
esse material é enviado para a
plataforma e vira
e vira um e book é esse book ele fica
disponível para pais e professores de
forma gratuita
pais e professores podem então olhar
como ficou o livro de forma gratuita na
internet mas principalmente os pais
podem participar escrevendo a biografia
do próprio plano e os pais ainda podem
neste momento fazer a aquisição de
livros que vão ser utilizados no momento
mais importante dessa jornada que é o
dia de autógrafos no dia de autógrafos
que as crianças sim poderão ser um
vestido de gala pelos pais
eles ficam ansiosos para pegar o livro
assinar fazer uma dedicatória para os
pais é nesse momento que a gente conhece
histórias como o mistério da lasanha
dourada onde a heroína da história a
comida preferida do autor
acho que seria minha também histórias
como uma de uma menina que tendo os pais
cegos e eles não poderiam ler o livro
que ela fez
a gente conseguiu produzir a história em
braile e administrações em relevo
histórias como a de um menino de um de
aula de uma escola de alto padrão no rio
de janeiro que dizia que ele tinha tudo
e em todos os carrinhos camisas de
clubes de futebol que ele viajava todo
ano pra disney mas tinha uma coisa que
ele não tinha a presença do pai
histórias bom é se isso funcionou enfim
essas histórias nos levarão alguns
números bem significativo se isso
funcionou era uma aposta afinal só em
2017 a gente conseguiu atuar mais de
duas mil escolas foram 240 mil pequenos
autores só no ano passado a gente tem
uma expectativa para esse ano é que a
gente alcance com os números que a gente
tem aproximadamente meio milhão de
pequenos autores do brasil da argentina
do méxico na colômbia
isso porque as nossas pretensões elas
são um pouco maiores a gente quer chegar
a 1 bilhão
de crianças infectadas em 2030 a
proposta falando de internacionalização
a gente foi convidado para participar de
uma aula de inovação de educação em
favor de um começo desse ano
se contar uma história difícil mas nem
raiva em inglês
e aí vem aquela história na sua cabeça e
os pobres não chega a lugar nenhum vocês
nunca vão sair desse lugar de onde vocês
estão aí você entra e antes da
apresentação que você tinha treinado
professor fernando rick mears pergunta
robson
antes de começar porque eu queria que
você contasse a história da sua família
e de onde você veio
era um eco daquele guri onde você mora
mas dessa vez eu tinha até orgulho de
dizer pela minha própria história mas
não só por ela mas pela história de mais
240 mil crianças que a gente ajudou a
contar a própria história
é bom contar a própria história é um ato
de coragem de falar de seus medos dos
seus anseios das suas fantasias das suas
ideias malucas da sua comida preferida
mas isso em poder as crianças
isso faz com que elas percebam o valor
de escrever a própria história mas não
só para as crianças
imaginem os professores eles dizem que
aumenta a freqüência nas bibliotecas
depois que o antigo projeto é aplicado
que os alunos se engajam mais essas
professores por exemplo desenharam as
ilustrações das crianças do próprio
vestido
os pais dizem que passaram a freqüentar
mais a vida dos filhos passaram a ler
com os filhos e os filhos passaram a
pedir livros de presente olha só para as
crianças
afinal para quem a gente mais trabalho
a gente tem relato de como eu não sabia
que eu podia inscrever no próprio livro
mas eu consegui ou ainda eu já estou
pensando na minha próxima história do
meu próximo livro
ou ainda obrigado por fazerem meus
sonhos virarem realidade ainda que no
papel
evidentemente existe um potencial sócio
emocional incrível nesse projeto
a gente está falando de autonomia de
autoconfiança e está falando de
reconhecimento e a educação precisa
fazer sentido a educação precisa
emocionar falar em emoção eu queria
concluir com uma última história
rapidamente quando estava fazendo
vestibular
eu fui na casa do meu avô e chegando lá
pela primeira vez eu vi meu avô choroso
tava chorando
imagina meu avô cara do interior do
ceará dos anos 30 sinal nunca sou forte
e de repente eu estava chorando na sala
e eu resolvi perguntar pro meu avô que
tinha acontecido e levou o que aconteceu
hoje morreu ea dona raquel era um
cliente meu avô mas mais do que uma
cliente era uma amiga sempre da anatel
para cada marca para lá olha guarda um
pedaço de jataí que vai levar o
estuprador raquel ou às vezes quando ele
demorava estava colocando uma estante
lavrador aquele monte de livros que ela
tem
sem saber o que falar para ele naquele
momento e aí eu voltei pra casa quando
estava em casa tava passando o jornal
hoje
estava almoçando e de repente vem a
notícia
morreu hoje no rio de janeiro à primeira
mulher a entrar para a academia
brasileira de letras a escritora raquel
de queiroz
eu não podia imaginar que meu avô um
cara humilde podia ser amigo da maior
escritora do país
eu voltei pra casa do meu avô com aquilo
na cabeça e ele falou que estava se
arrumando para o velório
destruindo a por cento a irmã dela ligou
até passando na televisão nesse momento
eu não agüentei falei vou ser amigo da
raquel de querer sair e eu não sabia
como assim você não contou ela é famosa
eu estudo ela na escola todo mundo
conhece
eu vou respondeu eu não sabia que ela
era famosa e nem poderia saber qual faz
parte dos milhões de analfabetos que
esse país produziu é uma falta de acesso
à educação
duas semanas depois eu visitei a casa do
meu avô era um almoço de família
eu sentei na cama tirou um livro do
fundo do armário terror com as duas mãos
e colocou no meu colo disse robson
esse livro não vai ter muita serventia
para mim como você disse que estuda ela
na escola eu acho que vai ser mais
importante para você pegar um livro nas
mãos o livro era torcedor aline raquel
de queiroz
eu abri tinha uma dedicatória ao senhor
pedro lembrança da raquel de queiroz 30
de junho de 2002
foi a segunda vez que eu vi eu vou
chorar
quantas histórias deixaram de ser
escritas pela falta de acesso à educação
computados pela falta da leitura
é por isso que a cada novo livro que a
gente publica que a cada nova
dedicatória a gente tenha certeza de que
cada história conta e eu tenho certeza
que dentro desta sala tem um monte de
história só esperando para ser contada
muito obrigado